The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I want to pick up
with a little bit of overlap
just to remind people
where we were.
We had been looking at
clustering, and we looked at a
fairly simple example of using
agglomerative hierarchical
clustering to cluster cities,
based upon how far apart they
were from each other cities.
So, essentially, using this
distance matrix, we could do a
clustering that would
reflect how close
cities were to one another.
And we went through a
agglomerative clustering, and
we saw that we would get a
different answer, depending
upon which linkage criterion
we used.
This is an important issue
because as one is using
clustering, one what has to be
aware that it is related to
these things, and you choose the
wrong linkage criterion,
you might get an answer other
than the most useful.
All right.
I next went on and said, well,
this is pretty easy, because
when we're comparing the
distance between two cities or
the two features, we just
subtract one distance from the
other and we get a number.
It's very straightforward.
I then raised the question,
suppose when we looked at
cities, we looked at a more
complicated way of looking at
them than airline distance.
So the first question, I said,
well, suppose in addition to
the distance by air, we add the
distance by road, or the
average temperature.
Pick what you will.
What do we do?
Well, the answer was we start by
generalizing from a feature
being a single number to the
notion of a feature vector,
where the features used to
describe the city are now
represented by a vector,
typically of numbers.
If the vectors are all in the
same physical units, we could
easily imagine how we might
compare two vectors.
So we might, for example, we
look at the Euclidean distance
between the two just by,
say, subtracting one
vector from the other.
However, if we think about
that, it can be pretty
misleading because, for example,
when we look at a
city, one element of the vector
represents the distance
in miles from another city,
or in fact this case, the
distance in miles
to each city.
And another represents
temperatures.
Well, it's kind of funny to
compare distance, which might
be thousands of miles,
with the temperature
which might be 5 degrees.
A 5 degree difference in average
temperature could be
significant.
Certainly a 20 degree difference
in temperature is
very significant, but a 20 mile
difference in location
might not be very significant.
And so to equally weight a 20
degree temperature difference
and at 20 miles distance
difference might give us a
very peculiar answer.
And so we have to think about
the question of, how are we
going to scale the elements
of the vectors?
Even if we're in the same
units, say inches,
it can be an issue.
So let's look at this example.
Here I've got on the left,
before scaling, something
which we can say is in inches,
height and width.
This is not from a person, but
you could imagine if you were
trying to cluster people, and
you measured their height in
inches and their width in
inches, maybe you don't want
to treat them equally.
Right?
But there's a lot more variance
in height than in
width, or maybe there is
and maybe there isn't.
So here on the left we don't
have any scaling, and we see a
very natural clustering.
On the other hand, we notice on
the y-axis the values range
from not too far from 0
to not too far from 1.
Whereas on the x-axis, the
dynamic range is much less,
not too far from 0 to not
too far from 1/2.
So we have twice the dynamic
range here than we have here.
Therefore, not surprisingly,
when we end up doing the
clustering, width plays
a very important role.
And we end up clustering
it this way,
dividing it along here.
On the other hand, if I take
exactly the same data and
scale it, and now the x-axis
runs from 0 to 1/2 and the
y-axis, roughly again, from 0
to 1, we see that suddenly
when we look at it
geometrically, we end up
getting a very different
look of clustering.
What's the moral?
The moral is you have to think
hard about how to cluster your
features, about how to scale
your features, because it can
have a dramatic influence
on your answer.
We'll see some real life
examples of this shortly.
But these are all the important
things to think
about, and they all, in some
sense, tie up into the same
major point.
Whenever you're doing any kind
of learning, including
clustering, feature, selection,
and scaling is critical.
It is where most of the thinking
ends up going.
And then the rest gets to
be fairly mechanical.
How do we decide what features
to use and how to scale them?
We do that using domain
knowledge.
So we actually have to think
about the objects that we're
trying to learn about and what
the objective of the learning
process is.
So continuing, how do
we do the scaling?
Most of the time, it's done
using some variant of what's
called the Minkowski metric.
It's not nearly as imposing
as it looks.
So the distance between two
vectors, X1 and X2, and then
we use p to talk about,
essentially, the degree we're
going to be using.
So we take the absolute
difference between each
element of X1 and X2, raise it
to the p-th power, sum them
and then take the 1 over p.
Not very complicated,
so let's say p is 2.
That's the one you people
are most familiar with.
Effectively, all we're
doing is getting
the Euclidean distance.
What we looked at when we looked
at the mean squared
distance between two things,
between our errors and our
measured data, between our
measured data and our
predicted data.
We used the mean square error.
That's essentially in Minkowski
distance with p
equal to 2.
That's probably the most
commonly used, but an almost
equally commonly used sets
p equal to 1, and that's
something called the
Manhattan distance.
I suspect at least some of you
have spent time walking around
Manhattan, a small but densely
populated island in New York.
And midtown Manhattan has
the feature that it's
laid out in a grid.
So what you have is a grid,
and you have the avenues
running north-south and the
streets running east-west.
And if you want to walk from,
say, here to here or drive
from here to here, you cannot
take the diagonal because
there are a bunch of buildings
in the way.
And so you have to move either
left or right, or up, or down.
That's the Manhattan distance
between two points.
This is used, in fact, for a
lot of problems, typically
when somebody is comparing the
distance between two genes,
for example, they use a
Manhattan metric rather than a
Euclidean metric to say how
similar two things are.
Just wanted to show that because
it is something that
you will run across in the
literature when you read about
these kinds of things.
All right.
So far, we've talked about
issues where things are
comparable.
And we've been doing that by
representing each element of
the feature vector as a
floating point number.
So we can run a formula like
that by subtracting
one from the other.
But we often, in fact, have to
deal with nominal categories,
things that have names
rather than numbers.
So for clustering people, maybe
we care about eye color,
blue, brown, gray, green.
Hair color.
Well, how do you compare
blue to green?
Do you subtract one
from the other?
Kind of hard to do.
What does it mean to subtract
green from blue?
Well, I guess we could talk
about it in the frequency
domain, enlighten things.
Typically, what we have to do
in that case is, we convert
them to a number and
then have some ways
to relate the numbers.
Again, this is a place where
domain knowledge is critical.
So, for example, we might
convert blue to 0, green to
0.5, and brown to 1, thus
indicating that we think blue
eyes are closer to green eyes
than they are to brown eyes.
I don't know why we think that
but maybe we think that.
Red hair is closer to blonde
hair than it is to black hair.
I don't know.
These are the sorts of things
that are not mathematical
questions, typically,
but judgments that
people have to make.
Once we've converted things to
numbers, we then have to go
back to our old friend of
scaling, which is often called
normalization.
Very often we try and contrive
to have every feature range
between 0 and 1, for example,
so that everything is
normalized to the same
dynamic range,
and then we can compare.
Is that the right thing to do?
Not necessarily, because you
might consider some features
more important than others
and want to give
them a greater weight.
And, again, that's something
we'll come
back to and look at.
All this is a bit abstract.
I now want to look
at an example.
Let's look at the example
of clustering mammals.
There are, essentially, an
unbounded number of features
you could use, size at birth,
gestation period, lifespan,
length of tail, speed,
eating habits.
You name it.
The choice of features and
weighting will, of course,
have an enormous impact on
what clusters you get.
If you choose size, humans might
appear in one cluster.
If you choose eating habits,
they might appear in another.
How should you choose which
features you want?
You have to begin by choosing,
thinking about the reason
you're doing the clustering
in the first place.
What is it you're trying to
learn about the mammals?
As an example, I'm going
to choose the
objective of eating habits.
I want to cluster mammals
somehow based
upon what they eat.
But I want to do that, and
here's a very important thing
about what we often see in
learning without any direct
information about
what they eat.
Typically, when we're using
machine learning, we're trying
to learn about something
for which we have
limited or no data.
Remember when we talked about
learning, I talked about
learning in which it was
supervised, and which we had
some data, and unsupervised,
in which, essentially, we
don't have any labels.
So let's say we don't have any
labels about what mammals eat,
but we do know a lot about
the mammals themselves.
And, in fact, the hypothesis I'm
going to start with here
is that you can infer people's
or creatures' eating habits
from their dental records,
or their dentitian.
But over time, we have evolved,
all creatures have
evolved, to have teeth that are
related to what they eat,
we can see.
So I managed to procure a
database of dentitian for
various mammals.
There's the laser pointer.
So what I've got here
is the number of
different kinds of teeth.
So the right top incisors, the
right bottom incisors, molars,
et cetera, pre-molars.
Don't worry if you don't know
about teeth very much.
I don't know very much.
And then for each animal,
I have the number of
each kind of tooth.
Actually, I don't have it for
this particular mammal, but
these two I do.
I don't even remember
what they are.
They're cute.
All right.
So I've got that database, and
now I want to try and see what
happens when I cluster them.
The code to do this is not very
complicated, but I should
make a confession about it.
Last night, I won't
say I learned it.
I was reminded of a lesson that
I've often preached in
6.00, is that it's not good to
get your programming done at
the last minute.
So as I was debugging this code
at 2:00 and 3:00 in the
morning today, I was realizing
how inefficient I am at
debugging at that hour.
Maybe for you guys that's
the shank of the day.
For me, it's too late.
I think it all works, but I was
certainly not at my best
as I was debugging last night.
All right.
But at the moment, I don't want
you to spend time working
on the code itself.
I would like you to think a
little bit about the overall
class structure of the code,
which I've got on the first
page of the handout.
So at the bottom of my
hierarchy, I've got something
called a point, and that's an
abstraction of the things to
be clustered.
And I've done it in quite a
generalized way, because, as
you're going to see, the code
we're looking at today, I'm
going to use not only for
clustering mammals but for
clustering all sorts of
other things as well.
So I decided to take the trouble
of building up a set
of classes that would
be useful.
And in this class, I can have
the name of a point, its
original attributes.
That say its original feature
vector, an unscaled feature
vector, and then whether or not
I choose to normalize it.
I might have normalized
features as well.
Again, I don't want you worry
too much about the
details of the code.
And then I have a distance
metric, and I'm just for the
moment using simple Euclidean
distance.
The next element in my
hierarchy, not yet a
hierarchy--
it's still flat--
is a cluster.
And so what a cluster is, you
can think of it as, at some
abstract level, it's just going
to be a set of points,
the points that are
in the cluster.
But I've got some other
operations on it
that will be useful.
I can compute the distance
between two clusters, and as
you'll see, I have single
linkage, Mac Link, max ,
average, the three I talked
about last week.
And also this notion
of a centroid.
We'll come back to that when we
get to k-means clustering.
We don't need to worry right
now about what that is.
Then I'm going to have
a cluster set.
That's another useful
data abstraction.
And that's what you might guess
from its name, just a
set of clusters.
The most interesting operation
there is merge.
As you saw, when we looked at
hierarchical clustering last
week, the key step there is
merging two clusters.
And in doing that, I'm going to
have a function called Find
Closest, which given a metric
and a cluster, finds the
cluster that is most similar to
that, to self, because as
you, again, will recall from
hierarchical clustering,
that's what I merged at
each step is the two
most similar clusters.
And then there's some details
about how it works, which
again, we don't need to worry
about at the moment.
And then I'm going to have a
subclass of point called
Mammal, in which I will
represent each mammal by the
dentitian as we've
looked at before.
Then pretty simply, we can do
a bunch of things with it.
Before we look at the other
details of the code, I want to
now run it and see
what we get.
So I'm just going to use
hierarchical clustering now to
cluster the mammals based upon
this feature vector, which
will be a list of numbers
showing how many of each kind
of tooth the mammals have.
Let's see what we get.
So it's doing the merging.
So we can see the first step, it
merged beavers with ground
hogs and it merged grey
squirrels with porcupines,
wolves and bears.
Various other kinds of things,
like jaguars and cougars, were
a lot alike.
Eventually, it starts doing
more complicated merges.
It merges a cluster containing
only the river otter with one
containing a Martin and a
wolverine, beavers and ground
hogs with squirrels and
porcupines, et cetera.
And at the end, I had it
stop with two clusters.
It came up with these
clusters.
Now we can look at these
clusters and say, all right.
What do we think?
Have we learned anything
interesting?
Do we see anything
in any of these--
do we think it makes sense?
Remember, our goal was to
cluster mammals based upon
what they might eat.
And we can ask, do we think
this corresponds to that?
No.
All right.
Who-- somebody said--
Now, why no?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: We've got-- like a
deer doesn't eat similar
things as a dog.
And we've got one type on the
top cluster and a different
kind of bat in the
bottom cluster.
Seems like they would be
even closer together.
PROFESSOR: Well, sorry.
Yeah.
A deer doesn't eat what a dog
eats, and for that matter, we
have humans here, and while
some human are by choice
vegetarians, genetically,
humans are essentially
carnivores.
We know that.
We eat meat.
And here we are with a bunch
of herbivores, typically.
Things are strange.
By the way, bats might end up
being in ones, because some
bats eat fruit, other bat eat
insects, but who knows?
So I'm not very happy.
Why do you think we got this
clustering that maybe isn't
helping us very much?
Well, let's go look at
what we did here.
Let's look at test 0.
So I said I wanted
two clusters.
I don't want it to print all
the steps along the way.
I'm going to print the
history at the end.
And scaling is identity.
Well, let's go back and look
at some of the data here.
What we can see is--
or maybe we can't see too
quickly, looking at all this--
is some kinds of teeth have
a relatively small range.
Other kinds of teeth
have a big range.
And so, at the moment, we're not
doing any normalization,
and maybe what we're doing is
getting something distorted
where we're only looking at a
certain kind of tooth because
it has a larger dynamic range.
And in fact, if we look at the
code, we can go back up and
let's look at Build Mammal
Points and Read Mammal Data.
So Build Mammal Points calls
Read Mammal Data, and then
builds the points.
So Read Mammal Data is the
interesting piece.
And what we can see here
is, as we read it in--
this is just simply reading
things in, ignoring comments,
keeping track of things--
and then we come down here,
I might do some scaling.
So Point.Scale feature is using
the scaling argument.
Where's that coming from?
If we look at Mammal Teeth, here
from the mammal class, we
see that there are two ways to
scale it, identity, where we
just multiply every element
in the vector by 1.
That doesn't change anything.
Or what I've called
1 over max.
And here, I've looked at the
maximum number of each kind of
tooth and I'm dividing
1 by that.
So here we could have up
to three of those.
Here we could have
four of those.
We could have six of this kind
of tooth, whatever it is.
And so we can see, by dividing
by the max, I'm now putting
all of the different kinds of
teeth on the same scale.
I'm normalizing.
And now we'll see, does that
make a difference?
Well, since we're dividing
by 6 here and 3 here, it
certainly could make
a difference.
It's a significant scaling
factor, 2X.
So let's go and change the
code, or change the test.
And let's look at Test 0--
0, not "O"--
with scale set to 1 over max.
You'll notice, by the way, that
rather than using some
obscure code, like scale equals
12, I use strings so I
remember what they are.
It's, I think, a pretty useful
programming trick.
Whoops.
Did I use the wrong
name for this?
Should be scaling?
So off it's going.
Now we get a different set of
things, and as far as I know,
once we've scaled things, we
get what I think is a much
more sensible pair, where I
think what we essentially have
is the herbivores down here,
and the carnivores up here.
Ok.
I don't care how much you
know about teeth.
The point is scaling
can really matter.
You have to look at it, and you
have to think about what
you're doing.
And the interesting thing here
is that without any direct
evidence about what mammals
eat, we are able to use
machine learning, clustering in
this case, to infer a new
fact that we have some mammals
that are similar in what they
eat, and some mammals that are
also similar, some groups.
Now I can't infer from this
herbivores versus carnivores
because I didn't have any
labels to start with.
But what I can infer is that,
whatever they eat, there's
something similar about these
animals, and something similar
about these animals.
And there's a difference between
the groups in C1 and
the groups in C0.
I can then go off and look at
some points in each of these
and then try and figure out
how to label them later.
OK, let's look at a difference
data set, a far more
interesting one, a richer one.
Now, let's not look at
that version of it.
That's too hard to read.
Let's look at the Excel
spreadsheet.
So this is a database I found
online of every county in the
United States, and a bunch of
features about that county.
So for each county
in the United
States, we have its name.
The first part of the name
is the state it's in.
The second part of the name is
the name of the county, and a
bunch of things, like the
average value of homes, how
much poverty, its population
density, its population
change, how many people are
over 65, et cetera.
So the thing I want you to
notice, of course, is while
everything is a number, the
scales are very different.
It's a big difference between
the percent of something,
which will go between 0 and
100, and the population
density, which ranges over a
much larger dynamic range.
So we can immediately suspect
that scaling is going to be an
issue here.
So we now have a bunch of code
that we can use that I've
written to process this.
It uses the same clusters that
we have here, except I've
added a kind of Point
called the County.
Looks very different from a
mammal, but the good news is I
got to reuse a lot of my code.
Now let's run a test.
We'll go down here to Test 3,
and we'll see whether we can
do hierarchical clustering
of the counties.
Whoops.
Test 3 wants the name
of what we're doing.
So we'll give it the name.
It's Counties.Text.
I just exported the spreadsheet
as a text file.
Well, we can wait a while for
this, but I'm not going to.
Let's think about what we know
that hierarchical clustering
and how long this is
likely to take.
I'll give you a hint.
There are approximately 3,100
counties in the United States.
I'll bet none of you could
have guessed that number.
How many comparisons do we have
to find the two counties
that are most similar
to each other?
Comparing each county with every
other county, how many
comparisons is that
going to be?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's 3,100 choose 2.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that will be 3,100 squared.
Thank you.
And that's just the first
step in the cluster.
To perform the next merge, we'll
have to do it again.
So in fact, as we've looked at
last time, it's going to be a
very long and tedious process,
and one I'm not
going to wait for.
So I'm going to interrupt and
we're going to look at a
smaller example.
Here I've just got only the
counties in New England, a
much smaller number than
3,100, and I'm going to
cluster them using the exact
same clustering code we used
for the mammals.
It's just that the
points are now
counties instead of mammals.
And we got two clusters.
Middlesex County in
Massachusetts happens to be
the county in which
MIT is located.
And all the others--
well, you know, MIT is a pretty
distinctive place.
Maybe that's what did it.
I don't quite think so.
Someone got a hypothesis about
why we got this rather strange
clustering?
And is it because Middlesex
contains MIT and Harvard both?
This really surprised me, by the
way, when I first ran it.
I said, how can this be?
So I went and I started looking
at the data, and what
I found is that Middlesex County
has about 600,000 more
people than any other county
in New England.
Who knew?
I would have guessed Suffolk,
where Boston is, was the
biggest county.
But, in fact, Middlesex is
enormous relative to every
other county in New England.
And it turns out that difference
of 600,000, when I
didn't scale things, just
swamped everything else.
And so all I'm really getting
here is a clustering that
depends on the population.
Middlesex is big relative
to everything else and,
therefore, that's what I get.
And it ignores things like
education level and housing
prices, and all those other
things because the differences
are small relative to 600,000.
Well, let's turn scaling on.
To do that, I want to show you
how I do this scaling.
I did not, given the number
of features and number of
counties, do what I did for
mammals and count them by hand
to see what the maximum was.
I decided it would be a lot
faster even at 2:00 in the
morning to write
code to do it.
So I've got some code here.
I've got Build County Points,
just like Build Mammal Points
and Read County Data, like
Read Mammal Data.
But the difference here is,
along the way, as I'm reading
in each county, I'm keeping
track of the
maximum for each feature.
And then I'm just going
to just do the scaling
automatically.
So exactly the one over max
scaling I did for mammals'
teeth, I'm going to do it for
counties, but I've just
written some code to automate
that process because I knew I
would never be able
to count them.
All right, so now let's
see what happens if
we run it that way.
Test 3, New England, and
Scale equals True.
I'm either scaling it or not,
is the way I wrote this one.
And with the scaling on
again, I get a very
different set of clusters.
What have we got?
Where's Middlesex?
It's in one of these
2 clusters.
Oh, here it is.
It's C0.
But it's with Fairfield,
Connecticut and Hartford,
Connecticut and Providence,
Rhode Island.
It's a different answer.
Is it a better answer?
It's not a meaningful
question, right?
It depends what I'm trying to
infer, what we hope to learn
from the clustering, and that's
a question we're going
to come back to on Tuesday in
some detail with the counties,
and look at how, by using
different kinds of scaling or
different kinds of features, we
can learn different things
about the counties
in this country.
Before I do that, however,
I want to move
away from New England.
Remember we're focusing on New
England because it took too
long to do hierarchical
clustering of 3,100 counties.
But that's what I want to do.
It's no good to just
say, I'm sorry.
It took too long.
I give up.
Well, the good news is there
are other clustering
mechanisms that are much
more efficient.
We'll later see they, too,
have their own faults.
But we're going to look at
k-means clustering, which has
the big advantage of being fast
enough that we can run it
on very big data sets.
In fact, it is roughly linear
in the number of counties.
And as we've seen before, when
n gets very large, anything
that's worse than linear is
likely to be ineffective.
So let's think about
how k-means works.
Step one, is you choose k.
k is the total number of
clusters you want to have when
you're done.
So you start by saying, I want
to take the counties and split
them into k-clusters.
2 clusters, 20 clusters, a 100
clusters, 1,000 clusters.
You have to choose k
in the beginning.
And that it's one of the issues
that you have with
k-means clustering is,
how do you choose k?
We can talk about that later.
Once I've chosen k, I choose k
points as initial centroids.
You may remember earlier today
we saw this centroid method in
class cluster.
So what's a centroid?
You've got a cluster, and in
the clusters, you've got a
bunch of points scattered
around.
The centroid you can think of
as, quote, "the average
point," the center
of the cluster.
The centroid need not be any of
the points in the cluster.
So, again, you need
some metric.
But let's say we're
using Euclidean.
It's easy to see on the board.
The centroid is kind of there.
Now let's assume that we're
going to start by choosing
k-point from the initial
set and labeling each
of them as a centroid.
We often--
in fact, quite typically--
choose these at random.
So we now have k randomly chosen
points, each of which
we're going to call centroid.
The next step is to
assign each point
to the nearest centroid.
So we've got k-centroids.
We usually choose a
small k, say 50.
And now we have to compare each
of the 3,100 counties to
each of the 50 centroids, and
put each one in the correct
thing, in the closest.
So it's 50 times 3,100, which
is a lot smaller number than
3,100 squared.
So now I've got a clustering.
Kind of strange, because what it
looks like depends on this
random choice.
So there's no reason to expect
that the initial assignment
will give me anything
very useful.
Step (4) is, for each
of the k-clusters,
choose a new centroid.
Now remember, I just chose
at random k-centroids.
Now I actually have a cluster
with a bunch of points in it,
so I could, for example, take
the average of those and
compute a centroid.
And I can either take the
average, or I can take the
point nearest the average.
It doesn't much matter.
And then step (5) is one we've
looked at before, assign each
point to nearest centroid.
So now I'm going to get
a new clustering.
And then, (6) is repeat
(4) and (5) until
the change is small.
So each time I do step (5), I
can keep track of how many
points I've moved from one
cluster to another.
Or each time I do step (4), I
can say how much have I moved
the centroids?
Each of those gives me a measure
of how much change the
new iteration has produced.
When I get to the point where
the iterations are not making
much of a change--
and we'll see what we
might mean by that--
we stop and say, OK, we now
have a good clustering.
So if we think of the complexity
each iteration is
order k-n, where k is the number
of clusters, and n is
the number of points.
And then we do that step for
some number of iterations.
So if the number of iterations
is small, it will converge
quite quickly.
And as we'll see, typically for
k-means, we don't need a
lot of iterations to
get an answer.
It's typically not proportional
to n, in
particular, which is
very important.
All right.
Tuesday, we'll go over the code
for k-means clustering,
and then have some fun playing
with counties and see what we
can learn about where we live.
All right.
Thanks a lot.